the challenges of distance education and
the pandemic does not only
impact clark county school district
students it affects parents health and
well-being too
a news now reporter kristen drummond
shows us some resources available
families can access various free virtual
workshops
giving adults a place to go for support
during distance education
it definitely is a struggle be just
because i works
dad works celeste tran tries her best to
help her kindergartner during online
learning
my son knows i'm his mother so he's not
going to listen to me like how he's
going to listen to a teacher
creating a challenging situation i do
sometimes get emotional just because i
know my son's not learning at the pace
he should be learning
parents are stressed rebecca garcia is
president of the nevada parent teacher
association
she says various factors in the pandemic
create potentially frustrating
circumstances in homes
how do you create boundaries but virtual
workshops and seminars aim to help
nevada pta continues hosting panels
focusing not only on mental health but
parenting thank you so much for joining
for us it's really important that we try
to just provide as much information
and resources that we can for families
that's easily accessible ccsd family and
community engagement services or
faces is also offering virtual workshops
a change during the pandemics since
most engagement classes were on campuses
flyers online notify families of dates
registration deadlines and topics like
parenting during covet
which is on thursday the new format now
allows more families to access the
information
these online events are a good way for
people to quickly tune in
i appreciate it they are trying trying
to give tran and
other parents guidance during this time
kristin drummond
8 news now during distance education
faces has produced more content to try
to help families transition to online
learning now we have a link to resources
and upcoming events on eight newsnow dot
com
and parents eight news now will continue
to work to find out
when ccsd will reopen schools especially
in the wake of the cdc
dr fauci and the american academy of
pediatrics all
recommending a return to in-person
learning